There's no denying it: Director Andy Muschietti's
2017 adaptation of Stephen King's It was fifty
shades of freaky.
Well, prepare for things to get scarier, bloodier,
and way more traumatizing in the film's upcoming
sequel, It: Chapter Two.
It's just been confirmed that two extremely
controversial aspects of King's 1986 novel
have made it into the film.
Spoilers ahead!
Speaking to The Hollywood Reporter, screenwriter
Gary Dauberman revealed that It: Chapter Two
will include one of the most haunting scenes
in the book: - A horrific hate crime against
a young gay man named Adrian Mellon, who will
be portrayed by actor, writer, and director
Xavier Dolan.
In the book, Mellon becomes the victim of
a savage beating at the hands of three homophobic
teenagers, who throw him over a bridge.
Then, he's subsequently murdered by Pennywise
the Dancing Clown.
This subplot was conspicuously absent from
the 1990 television adaptation of It, but
the creative team behind the upcoming film
thought it was important to include Mellon's
story.
As Dauberman explained to The Hollywood Reporter:
"It is an iconic scene in the book and one
we wanted to include in the movie.
[...] It is the influence of Pennywise even
while he is hibernating, and it's pure evil
what happens to Adrian.
These bullies working through Pennywise was
important for us to show."
Another contentious aspect of King's novel
is the plight of adult Beverly Marsh, portrayed
by Jessica Chastain.
The second part of King's novel jumps ahead
27 years, and we learn that Marsh has become
a domestic abuse victim at the hands of her
husband Tom Rogan.
We now know this storyline is included in
It: Chapter Two, and the film closely mirrors
the events of the book.
As Dauberman explained, the whole production
wanted to remain true to the original novel.
It's safe to say the It sequel will outdo
the first installment on every front.
Dauberman promises that
"[The film is] definitely bloodier than the
first and it is just as scary, if not scarier."
Muschietti clearly agrees.
Over a year ago, he warned fans that they
should prepare to be rocked to the core, claiming
that,
"It's going to be scarier and more intense,
so bring your adult diapers to the movie theater."
Two more tidbits are sure to pique the interest
of any gorehound.
The film evidently features a scene that's
doused in a shocking amount of stage blood…
and Pennywise will reportedly be far more
savage this time around.
Chastain described the bloody sequence in
an interview with Jimmy Fallon:
“There's a scene that someone said on set
that it's the most blood that's ever been
in a horror film — in a scene."
Meanwhile, Pennywise actor Bill Skarsgård
told Entertainment Weekly that the creature
has only become stronger in the 27 years it
spent lying dormant in the Derry sewers.
And whereas Pennywise was once terrorizing
the children for sport, the ghastly creature
is now motivated by revenge.
As Skarsgård explains:
"It fuels hatred and anger towards the kids,
who will be adults in this one, so I think
there might be an even more vicious Pennywise.
He's really going after it."
It sounds like It: Chapter Two is going to
be truly terrifying, and the inclusion of
those two unsettling subplots from the book
will just make the film even more upsetting.
See how everything plays out when It: Chapter
Two floats into theaters on September 6th.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about It: Chapter
Two are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.